j'ai mon frère qui s'appelle mohamed
hocine un prénom maghrébin il trouve pas
d'appartement il a un bon salaire
je suis son garant et l'initiation
stable ils voient que des refus c'est
mon ami le docteur coulibaly qui un jour
se baladait il est médecin avec un
poster dans le don un concert il se fait
arrêter par les policiers ils disent
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce poster
vous avez une autorisation de les vendre
c'est mon ami le docteur à masnysien qui
est neuroradiologue il est noir on lui
dit mais vous allez rentrer au pays chez
vous la cette année c'est ça le racisme
c'est le fait qu'on trouvera un emploi
c'est le fait qu'on soit discriminée
quand ce qu'on voit entend en boîte de
nuit
c'est le film en galère que c'est le n 1
mondial est attendue à genève pendant
que tu mets dans le jour le jour où
bernard n'émerge à bâle où j'ai encore
du mal à trouver un emploi aura du mal à
les opposer aura du mal à à true and
avoir un appartement là oui je mélange
est en train de nous expliquer du raf
est dit deux minutes et dix
approuveraient retenant juste dit mixu
vous êtes en train de nous expliquer que
vous êtes en train de nous nous
d'expliquer ce qu'est le racisme alors
on fait la galère de tous les jours de
mamadou paul et de mohamed ça n'a rien à
voir au plus à vous attendre à nous dire
que vous jimmy à trouver du travail mais
pas mohamed ben franchement mon prénom
je pense sûrement parce que je vois je
vois les difficultés de mes amis les
gens toujours des gens diplômés qui
galère qui se disait mais pourquoi je
suis là j'ai calé ailleurs dans ces cas
là c'est le racisme du quotidien leurs
assistants et qui donne l'accès à une
fonction un logement un statut social
et lorsqu'on a le racisme ça concerne
souvent des minorités le aux verts par
exemple les homosexuels les juifs non
mais là on a notamment on est blanc je
ne vois pas comment le mélangeant
peuvent être mais londres insiste
pourtant si ce n'est quand il n'ya pas
de racisme là tu es en train de nous
expliquer le racisme anti arabe dont il
doit bien sûr et que j'explique de
laisser la situation est la suivante
pendant des années en france les noirs
et des arabes ont été perçue uniquement
comme victime victime de racisme
victimes de discrimination et il l'était
et il continue à l'aide de ce point de
vue là jimmy a tout à fait raison
évidemment comme il était victime ça
aurait été de très mauvais goût de
vérifier s'il avait pas des racistes
parmi eux aussi et puis finalement un
jour on a été obligé d'ouvrir les yeux
c'est à dire que dans certains coins on
entend une insulte qui est sale français
si tu une femme s'habille en jupe en
robe elle est traitée de [ __ ] à français
il ya donc un racisme anti français
disons anti blancs et moi ce qui me
consterne le plus ça c'est des petits
cons est bon il faut sévir de ces petits
cons mais moi ce qui me consterne le
plus c'est sûr âme qui pratique une
autre forme de racisme
il pratique la base même du racisme et
l'essentialisation pour lui il ya les
blancs en général les blancs van damme
et locke et ces gens là aurait selon lui
une position mais présent moi comme tout
le monde on est raflée par thuram en
disant vous avez comme une position et
méprisante le langage de tous victor
l'événement raciste par les noirs en
général ou des arabes en général les
noirs et des arabes raciste parle des
blats projet n'a c'est la mairie secours
il y a deux années en france vikash
dhorasoo nous on parle de nous pas
forcément quand on dit les noirs et les
arabes
c'est pas forcément du racisme moi ça me
pose aucun problème qu'on me dise les
noirs quand on parle de moi c'est pas ça
le racisme c'est discriminer comme vous
dites épices à une histoire ça a été la
dépense on a pris des noirs on les as de
déportés on les a colonisé parfois on
les a fait travailler pour s'enrichir et
ça c'est les blancs qu'ils ont fait et
ensuite on verra si le ratio à damas le
racisme a été inventée justement pour
justifier chez domination et cet
esclavage parce qu'il fallait justement
puisqu'on l'eredivisie à l'état de
d'anim d'animaux le message final
oui mais oui massa se perpétue ça
continue à domination des blancs et vous
connais bien mais si c'est la douceur
des nuits d'hôtel et politiquement ça
continue à être toutes les grandes
organisations mondiales même dans l'état
il n'y a pas de diversité il n'y a pas
de noix n'ya pas d'arabe
on a obligé la famille
non mais ont trouvé leur côté ocde
le g7 encore une fois la récemment trois
femmes toutes les cheveux les chefs
d'état dont une femme et chef d'état
c'était que des blancs et c'est comme ça
moi je veux jouer au football juste un
exemple nous sommes 60 % de noirs et
d'arabes à jouer au football
l'unecatef leurs représentants des
syndicats des entraîneurs il n'y a pas
un seul noir le cojo qui va organiser le
comité de olympique des jeux de
coordination des jeux olympiques qui va
préparer les jeux olympiques il ya anwar
bruno marie-rose le gouvernement combien
lee ann ware une femme si bête c'est
tout rien d'autre et c'est comme ça donc
on nous ont une seule autorité ne soit
pas on ne nous autorise pas on nous
permet pas d'accéder et de ça c'est du
racisme est donc juste pour finir c'est
fini
non non non non non mais on vous disait
que j'aimerais jouer car grâce à vous il
n'ya pas de racisme anti-blancs donc
vikash maillot n'y a pas de racisme anti
blanc parce que le délégué a déjà déjà
pourquoi il ya du racisme
pourquoi on doit rajouter antilles dont
j'aimerais savoir qui a théorisé sur
racine motivant ça vient de l'extrême
droite évidemment essayer donc je suis
j'imagine
eric zemmour peut-être où je ne suis pas
d'extrême droite alors c'est juste pour
finir s'il vous plaît j'aimerais nous le
racisme il est expliqué par des gens qui
ont subi racisme il ya eu bartains
luther king james baldwin dias baldwin
il raconte un truc extraordinaire quand
il était aux états unis il a subi le
racisme
donc ils avaient peur se retourner afin
de prendre une balle dans le dos
notamment des flics parce que c'était
très dur à ségrégation et c est un jour
il est venu en france il s'est dit ça y
est pas franc ce pays l'universalisme
des droits de l'homme le pays des
lumières je suis enfin libre la première
journée s'est embarqué par les flics
à partir de ce moment là ce n'est que
s'il est vraiment les images de mares et
voilà faites-moi fini al saoud et c'est
ça la différence c'est que moi quand je
suis noir je risque de me faire
contrôler par les riddick les blu ray
fabula y voilà vous les blancs vous les
blancs mais non des bd pour nous
en duel on demande la gagner s'il vous
plaît pas répond très bas ce décor
domination il ya une utilisation afin de
profiler noir qui karim zéribi c'est
pour moi j'ai notamment lors de la
planète j'aime pas la domination
comment ça a été organisé pour nous
utiliser ça sonne berg vêtu
ici c'est le départ est massivement tu
joues si vous habitez ça ça veut dire
que thuram ne pourra plus jamais
combattre le racisme
si vous mettez ça au même plan c'est à
dire que nous nous sommes foutus si nous
combattons dans le film à peindre sur
thuram et la fesci sur elle le fait à
chaque fois un mini-terrain racistes
anti blancs parce que tu défends les
noirs alors ça veut dire que son
emplacement il acculèrent union parce
qu'il a dit là il est vous avez donc